you're traveling in some type of strange
fantasy land and you're trying to get
the cat get to the castle up here to
save the princess or the prince or
whomever you are trying to save but to
get there you have to cross this river
you can't swim across it's a very rough
river so you have to cross this bridge
and so as you approach the bridge this
troll shows up
that's the troll and he says well i'm a
reasonable troll you just have to pay
five dollars and when you look a little
bit more carefully you see that there
actually was a sign there that says five
dollars five dollars told to cross the
bridge
now unfortunately for you you do not
have any money in your pocket and says
the troll says well you can't cross but
you say i need to really really get to
that castle and so the troll says well
i'll take some pity on you instead of
paying the five dollars i will give you
i will give you
a riddle
and the riddle is this and now i'm
speaking as the troll i am a rich troll
because i get to charge five dollars
from everyone who crosses the bridge and
actually i only accept five or ten
dollar bills it's a bit of a riddle why
they accept american currency in this
fantasy land but let's just take that as
a given for now so i only take five or
ten dollar bills i'm being the troll
obviously if you give me a ten i'll give
you five back
and i know
because i count my money on a daily
basis i i like to save my money as the
troll i know that i have a total of
i have a total of
900 bills
so let me write that down i have a total
of 900 bills
total of
900
5 and 10 dollar bills
dollar
bills
and he says i will give you because i'm
very sympathetic i'll give you another
piece of information he says if you were
to add up the value of all of my money
which is all in five and ten dollar
bills
value
of all
the five and ten dollar bills that i
have i speaking is a troll
but dollar bills
is
5500 this is a rich troll is 5500
and so the riddle is exactly exactly and
if you give the wrong answer and if
you're not able to solve it in 10
minutes he's just going to push you into
the river or do something horrible to
you he says exactly how many
how many
fives
and tens
tens
do i
the troll
the troll have
so the first thing i'm going to have you
think about is is this even a solvable
problem because it's not a solvable
problem you should probably run as fast
as you can in the other direction
so now i will tell you yes it is a
solvable problem and let's start
thinking about it a little bit
algebraically and to do that let's just
set some variables and i will set the
variables to be what we're really trying
to solve for we're trying to solve for
the number of five dollar bills we have
and the number of ten dollar bills that
we have so let's just define some
variables i'll say f for five let's let
let's let f equal the number of five
dollar bills five dollar
five dollar bills
that we have and you i'll use the same
idea let's let t is equal to the number
the number of ten dollar
ten dollar bills that we have
now given this information and now i'm
not sure if i'm speaking as well let's
say i'm still speaking as a troll i'm a
very sympathetic troll and i'm going to
give you hints given this information
setting these variables in this way can
i represent the clues and the riddle
mathematically so let's focus on the
first clue can i represent this clue
that the total of 900 5 and 10 bills or
that can i represent that mathematically
that i have a total of 900 5 and 10
bills
well what's going to be our our total of
bills is going to be the number of fives
that we have which is f the number of
fives that we have is f
and then the number of tens that we have
is t
the total number of fives plus the total
number of tens that's our total number
of bills so that's going to be
that's going to be equal to 900. so this
statement this first clue in our riddle
the first clue in our riddle can be
written mathematically like this if we
defined the variables like that and i
just set f for 5 because f 5 and t for
10.
now let's look at the second clue
can we represent this one
can we represent this one mathematically
given these variable definitions that we
created
well let's think separately
about the value of the five dollar bills
and the value of the ten dollar bills
what's the value of all of the five
dollar bills
well each five dollar bill is worth five
dollars so it's going to be five times
the number of five dollar bills that we
have so if i have one five dollar bill
it will be five dollars if i have a
hundred five dollar bills that's going
to be five hundred dollars however five
many five dollar bills i just multiply
it by five that's the value of the five
dollar bills let me write that down
value
of the five dollar five dollar bills
now same logic what's the value of the
ten dollar bills
well the value of the ten dollar bills
is just going to be 10 times however
many bills i have
value
of
the 10 bills so what's going to be the
total value of my bills what's going to
be the value of the 5 bills
plus the value of the ten dollar bills
and he tells me what that total value is
it's 5500 so if i add these two things
they're going to add up to be 55
5500
so the second statement we can represent
mathematically with this second with
this second equation right over here
and what we essentially have right over
here we have two equations each of them
have two unknowns and just using one of
these equations we can't really figure
out what f and t are you can pick a
bunch of different combinations that add
up to 900 here you could pick up a pick
a bunch of different combinations where
if you work out all the math you get 500
5500 here so independently these these
equations you don't know what f and t
are but what we will see over the next
several videos is that if you use both
of this information if you say that
there's an f and a t that has to satisfy
both of these equations
then you can find a solution and this is
called a system of equations
this is a system of equations let me
write that down system
of
equations